sentiment que c'est très dur ces gens
supportent très dures de sa bière à
blanc la séquence mais malgré tout est
là elle a effectivement il n'est pas
dans une victime comme ça passe il a de
la répartie elle a de l'humour mama à la
crainte de la répartie d'ailleurs aller
avec nos téléphones c'est la première
fois qu'elle va réagir à ces à ces
séquences pepita merci pepita d'être
avec nous en quoi le mental est viril
merci bel et bien tu sais quoi chez cicc
je t'adore mais vraiment tu sais que
celle inclue mais vraiment je te jure je
te kiffe et je suis très content de le
tabac au téléphone il paraît que tu es
tu as ta pas bien réagi quand tu as vu
le buzz autour de toute cette séquence
ben oui ça a été extrêmement violent de
pour moi mais pas du tout dans le sens
où la maison de la majeure partie des
gens ont réagi à ce que moi je regardais
pas les laisser aux je l'enregistrais
j'étais sur autre chose et c'est
quelqu'un qui m'a appelé pour me dire
qu'ils étaient outrés par ces images
c'est scandaleux la bible il est évident
fois il ne parle et m'en bats les
messages ont du coup je fais sur la
partie que j'ai enregistrée et j'arrive
assez fréquentes début je vois ma bouche
et m'a dit dont deux des cinq journées
du métayage devait s'atteler
après je vois les trois séquences et là
mon sang n'a fait qu'un tour
parce que vraiment comme ça il s'élance
et c'était vraiment me jauger racisme et
j'ai dit ils se sont servis de moi tu
pour faire ça parce que c'est qu'à mon
pain c'est pas des images des plesses et
je ne te laisserai jamais jamais je suis
enragé un jeune homme est accusé patrice
laurent le plâtre ou me dira hamid deux
graphistes ou de misogyne des gens là
m'ont super protégés ils ont même poussé
pour que j'aille plus loin dans mes
délires parce que moi j'étais à peu par
et tous les tacles et sans adresse ont
remonté dans le temps vous suivez vous
voyez l'évolution c'est eux qui m'ont
donné je ne supporte pas qu'on salisse
cette émission parce que j'ai vraiment
vécu des moments père merveilleux que on
se sert de moi pour les faire passer
pour raciste parce que là où j'étais
encore le plus outré sécu mon but
milliers ceux qui m'ont blessé et tmc
parce que ils ont fait une émission je
sais pas si vous l'avez regardé où il
parlait justement du coeur du problème
de l'afpan dans le temps et tout ce qui
s'en suit
les femmes concernées qui était encore
2e de monter ces dires étaient invités
sur le plaqueur et commenter les images
mais moi m'a jamais prévenu ne sera pas
à me demander mon avis exact je vois les
images je comprends pas ce que tu as été
prévenue sur les nounous droite dans la
tête
j'aurais dit ça sur mon père à la tête
de bouffe une victoire où je démolis
ça vous a fait du mal tu saisis mars
ressortent ah oui ça m'a fait beaucoup
de mal qui sortent comme ça et à votre
entourage aussi on a beaucoup de gens
qui ma famille les amis et getafe depuis
la diffusion je passe ma vie au
téléphone j'ai pas dormi tant de jours
et si j'étais scandalisé les dîners et
peut-être qu'on ne faut en effet pas
possible ça comment tu as pu et je reste
puisque montag et oui parce que nous ne
suivait à jamais à un moment donné on a
senti ça à quoi aimer g19 et je leur ai
senti je ne serai jamais rester en
direct la bonté
je vous dirai pas où ils vont claque
dans la tête
vous mettez le doigt sur quelque chose
mine de rien c'est très grave de
ressortir aussi d'image comme ça et de
faire des analyses comme ça je le dis
voilà je le dis franchement tronquée
parce que pepita là elle était
tranquille pepita elle a là rien demandé
à personne
elle se retrouve au centre de toutes les
polémiques son téléphone il paraît que
ça n'arrête pas de sonner un peu plus
répondre à son téléphone ni à sa femme
il n'y a rien du tout parce que toute la
journée
il ya des journalistes qui l'appelle il
ya des gens qui l'appellent ses devient
insupportable pour elle pepita chaussant
je sens très émue et je suis hantée très
énervé le jeu j'essaye de ne contrôler
parce que c'est u tmc au téléphone vous
avez eu qui t'aiment ces jeux c'est pur
effet plus c'était quelqu'un de
l'apprendre je fais pas qu'ils
m'attrapent conditions de l'émission
devant gomis oui oui et vous les méritez
son plateau pour un bep bac mais j'y
mets sont malades ils ont monté des
fautes des images pour en faire quelque
chose il me demanda mois de débats de
débattre acier ils ont vu la totalité
tu sais c'est vraiment dans la totalités
ressortez le racisme misogynie
saurimo réalité on en aurait parlé
ce n'était pas le cas il faut faire
message qu'ont les faire passer pour des
monstres
bon ça sort en touche pas à mon bateau
et on touche pas pyramide
j'étais bien avec eux et là ils ont
chalumeau c'est moi qu'ils ont fallu ils
ont joué
sera cheval mois mais leafs ont trait à
scott dans la tête on joue pas avec moi
on ne vit pas comme ça c'est pas
possible alors je peux comprendre que
certaines personnes qui sont blacks
comme moi tu as dû être hyper violent
pour eux mais je veux pas me lisent et
légumes à gérer mais ça a été d'autant
plus humide riant et blessant pour moi
parce que c'était faux projet le
producteur qui était mal à passer les 80
ans il était choqué parce que justement
sur pyramide on n'avait pas ce problème
et ce qui faisait notre force
parce que c'est un jeu où dix postes si
on comprend pas on joue surtout
vocabulaire français il y avait moi
cette espèce d'électronique qui
faisaient ce qu'ils voulaient gtc
c'est un super souvenir pour vous
pyramide et tmc à saly à saly 500 à lire
tout ça à tous et j'ai mes amis mes
proches tout le monde était scandalisé
et après vous avez vu ce qui a été
déversé sur patrice laurent sur les
réseaux sociaux nations du monde
oui le racisme le crif oui il a plein de
problèmes en ce moment et on met le
doigt dessous il ya le problème des
femmes c'est ce qui cartonne partons pas
comme ça et eux ils se sert de moi pour
alimenter ce débat à la ligne et suzanne
était honnête ni vraiment laids des
jeunes en aurait parlé mais par dessus
le marché il devrait soit dit les
séquences où on voit bien quel point moi
je les mouches moi je les démolit en
rigolant en disant que à la limite
battoir les ont ils tous préféré prendre
le côté des messieurs malhonnête ville
pour faire un buzz ils ont eu le buzz
parrainage de patiner de m'entendre les
familles un pépé tabou reste avec nous
on va apprendre que tu seras voir la
réaction de textes par exemple comme
dans tant de pepita c'est vrai que pour
déterrer des vieilles images comme c'est
ce que vous trouvez que c'est c'est
marrant c'est drôle c'est sympa ouvert
des analyses comme ça ou penser parce
que la pépite à jouer c'est vrai il ya
quelqu'un il est tranquille chez lui il
c'était son kiff il a fait son kit dans
l'émission c'était des magnifiques
souvenirs et ses des souvenirs qui sont
salis comme sa question se fait mal a
salué celle ça lui fait du mal un
pépites à saluer peta elle salue fait du
mal et voilà c'est là la déballer sur le
sur le devant le public tout ce qui fait
passer les années d'avant on voit deux
fautes faut pas faire ça quoi vraiment
ça fait du mal alors on va dire je la
rançon de la gloire
j'en ai pris aussi plein de kerouac
imagine bien je te le souhaite pas mais
je vous souhaite pas à vous tous mais on
sait bien qu'à un moment donné on va se
reprendre un coup de bâton un coup de
glaive de star wars
on va savoir un coup d'oeil aux à un
moment donné voilà cette pratique la
pression et qu'on est encore pépites à
qui tu voudrais qu'elle nous dise encore
ce qu'elle ressent c'est vrai qu'elle
était bizarre cette émission parce
qu'ils m'ont bien entendu qu'il vise 1
quand il disait oui tot petar oui quand
il disait que que le canton est le phare
on se prend des années
mais dans cette danse est dans les
épisodes qu'ils ont fait dans ce montage
pourri qu'ils ont fait des pâtes riz
c'est laurent qui tapait est pas moi moi
il faisait passer pour la peau petit bla
qui sait ce que c'est et malgré ces
chiffres et c'est là avec eux parce
qu'ils paniquent et travail l'esclave
qua non mais ça va pas leur tête des
journalistes qui vous ont appelé pour
vous dire si vous étiez choqué outre si
vous étiez malheureuse à l'époque de 2,2
dans cette émission il y en a qu'est-ce
qui est ce que vous leur avez répondu
oui vu tout à fait l'idée mais que
c'était honteux comme raison que vous
faire parce qu'ils arrêtaient que je
leur racontais j'ai fait mais dans une
rage ou m'auriez vu je tremblais après
j'étais désolé mais je ne vais pas être
isolé je veux pour les excusiez je m'en
fiche que ce soit à la télé mais vous
aviez laurent patrice la production et à
des pyramides et moi même que brigitte
désolé vous avez des forums
vous avez voulu faire un boeuf mais vous
aime a choisi quoi vous avez pris entre
guillemets pour qu'on comprenne ce que
je dis là seul black à la télé qu'il n'a
pas vécu ça je sais sûrement qu'ils ont
vécu mais moi je ne les ai pas vécu
bien au contraire on était entre nous en
rigoler en rigolait le public du coup le
public a évolué on avait des jeunes des
quarantenaires des dieux tout le monde
était là je suis même de moments je me
déguisais et où on s'éclate et pour moi
c'était une cour de récréation du cd
jeux qui m'ont touché profondément dans
mon coeur gilles verdez pétards reste
avec mon fils gilles verdez vous jugez
vous avez été choqué plane entendu comme
plein de gens parlent assez camby et
quand vous entendez pepita aujourd'hui
tisdale kick et qui aujourd'hui harceler
qui est en fait on a fait tomber son
rêve
on a fait tomber tout ce qu'elle avait
dans la tête d'où les rêves qu'elle
avait appelé tous les souvenirs
ils sont tombés à cause de cette
émission que vous lui répondez est
exactement et je vais faire ce que je
fais rarement celle de oui je vais pas
certaine
monde parce que quand on entend pépites
à l'émission de tmc a complètement
détourné les images les a sortis de leur
contexte c'est presque un mensonge c'est
qu'on l'a fait passer pour une victime
qu'on sent muni d'un assist ordinaire
alors qu'en fait c'est quelqu'un qui
luttait contre ça qu'ils se battaient et
qui en jouait la veine énorme répartie
est meilleur il encore là là là je dis
ap pita je suis totalement avec vous il
ya fait l'émission est totalement
anormale bravo pepita franchement okaya
mois toutes les façons quand j'ai vu les
images la première ville a été choquée
par les images de relever tous ces défis
moi j'ai vu les images j'ai dit merci
mais j'ai commencéà pepita en me disant
j'aimerais pas me retrouver au niveau au
milieu d'une polémique ou en fait je
n'ai pas de voix et en fait on a
l'impression que je suis une personne
passive et c'est vrai que j'ai une
pensée pour elle et je me suis demandé
si elle allait bien en pensant qu'à la
main sur ben et subissent à leur duel à
un autre discours maintenant il faut
qu'on n'avait plus fait dans l'attitude
de quotidien c'est vraiment cette
manière de se donner bonne conscience en
déterrant des images du passé je suis
désolé mais quotidien il ya quelques
mois ils ont reçu nicolas sarkozy qui a
prononcé des mots qui sont intolérables
et n'ont pas réagi sur le coup et je
trouve qu'il ya quelque chose de très
humain espèce de postures mois deux
rôles à la mondiaux en 1985 95 c'était
horrible sans demander l'avis en fait
des premières personnes concernées alors
qu'ils ne font pas leur propre examen de
conscience c'est ça que je trouve un
petit peu facile et un petit peu
caricatural 1 vous leur en voulez
aujourd'hui
pepita comment vous leur en voulez
aujourd'hui ah oui ah oui mais j'aurais
préféré qu'on parle pas de vous qu'on
vous laisse tranquille quoi
non mais lui voulait parler de la
passion la famille ils veulent pas l'âge
de la nec qui disent la vérité que wigan
à une époque c'était comme ça mais à mon
époque j'ai eu la sionge été gâté par
des gens tout ce qui passait à
l'extérieur ce convoi panneaux n'était
que la petite amie de pyramide quoi
pepita vous avez patrice laffont
téléphone non non j'ai pas voulu
l'embêter avec ça parce que c'est eux
qui étaient visés c'est monstrueux alors
nicolas pernikoff l'a eu nicolas
personnes âgées patrice laffont tout
d'abord je réponds juste un truc je suis
écoeuré chou ça dégueulasse à la manière
dont ça a été fait parce que d'abord on
est en 1995
c'est la première femme animatrice noir
que patrice laffont va mettre à
l'antenne
et effectivement c'est une famille et
j'ai eu patrice toute sa famille se fait
insulter sur les réseaux sociaux depuis
ce buzz
ces emprunts axel fabrice je trouve ça
tellement dégueulasse il faut remettre
les choses en contexte et en plus pépite
alloudi elle même c'est un jeu qu'elle
avait avec patrice laffont c'était une
vraie famille qui avait autour d'elle
donc c'est écoeurant
julien je pense qu'on aurait fait nous
le même montage bien dire ça aurait été
un drame absolu ç'aurait été ça aurait
été repris par le csa en lorraine on
parle de maths de manipulation l'image
c'est quelque chose de répréhensible
c'est extrêmement grave il y avait ils
font partie d'un postulat de départ on
va démontrer rue qui n'existe pas c'est
épouvantable voix cdb top excusez moi de
payer deux pays totalitaires voilà on
veut démontrer quelque chose on vous
accuse est pourri comme par hasard parce
que c'est bon gomis au monde et sera du
bon côté du trottoir là bien pensants ce
que des bobos ils ont fait ça et ses
rites on fait ça on est pas sympa parce
que ce genre de show d'abord un sapho
bordel dans la société on n'a pas besoin
de ça en ce moment c'est extrêmement
grave et je moi je trouve ça pas
vraiment tendre et où seule vérité j'ai
vu les images j'ai je dis tout j'ai dit
franchement gumi ils ont fait un travail
exceptionnel et l'animation était très
réussie je dis la vérité et se sent un
peu comme vous comme gilles ce soit
j'écoute pepita et là j'ai en fait j'ai
tourné je me dis c'est quand même
incroyable ignorions foutu ont foutu
c'est s'il rêve en l'air se laissait pas
faire
le pet à moi je sais que on regardait
aussi l'émission pour ça parce qu est ce
qu il s est pas fait bien sûr avec
patrice et avec laurent s est s était
dans ce jeu là que tout le monde
trouvait sa place
c'est un échange de vannes cela c'est la
guerre des vannes voilà c'était à
l'époque où la télévision lecteur
rigolote à excuser moi
moi j'ai choisi avec qui j'allais lui
perd manning les choix levier et oui
bien sûr mais c'était mon choix là qu'on
vous dit que s'ils vivent ils le
répètent ad s'arrêter à taulé etienne
c'est la tête a fait un tollé mais tous
les mac notamment d'un génie tout le
monde a crié j'ai tourné à lille s'était
formée avec moi le premier voilà vous
dirait aujourd'hui je change d'avis en
vous écrivant
et juste pepita qu'est ce que vous
diriez à la production de l'émission et
à l'animateur de l'émission qui ce que
vous avez envie de leur dire ce soir
c'est ce que je leur ai dit à la fois ça
a duré près de trois quarts d'heure
quand je les ai eus au téléphone et déjà
qu'il était désolé mais d'abord quitter
tout ce que j'ai à dire que j'ai été
blessé et tout c'est dégueulasse et puis
pour une première que j'aurais dit que
tu aurais pu être interrompue
intéressant eux mêmes ils se sont ils se
sont fait voter en faisant ça sous ce
qu'ils ont gagné c'est faire du mal aux
gens détruire des relations eu
j'apprends que patrice se faire sucrer
et thoune mais on va où
tout ça pour pas le buzz sur une
émission tepa de la crise a fait des
dégâts
laissez pas professionnel votre famille
elle vous a dit quoi pepita ab moi j'ai
ma mamma dernière petite soeur qui
m'envoie un message est une pépite a
condamné mais j'aurais jamais cru qu'il
n'aime pas j'ai arrêté je suis suivi les
émissions et smm culpabiliser parce
qu'elle s'est dit dans ma famille on dit
mais comment nous n'a pu louper tard
qu'elle était maltraitée parce qu'il
était super bien payé le montage
ils savaient très bien ce qu'ils aient
mon n'ont pas parlé ils m'ont rien dit
et qu'après m'appelle vous voulez vous
revenir sur le plateau mais ils ont de
la chance que je la passe en place et je
trime lille après tout la texane adoré
mon fils ils jouent au ping pong on
retarde habile et ont retardé le
tournage il voulait faire partie de ping
pong bas il va faire un tout bon quand
il veut avec moi je te le dis ma paie
pas comme un joueur monte saturée baba
vas-y vas-y reviennent le mois pepita je
voulais te dire que je t'embrasse très
très fort d'accord je t'en aller et on
peut lui en même temps que l a très bien
travaillé quand tu étais à la télé
c'était en effet pirate était
exceptionnel sache le il fallait parfois
et puis je voudrais si je fais pas su
patrice veux mon temps et l'oranje les
lg zèle que je n'accepte pas et puis
arrêtez arrêtez de cracher ce raid que
c'était des sommes vraiment très bien
j'étais heureuse très protecteur très
aisément
il était là qu'on avait un problème
laissez les tranquille est la limite
présenté leurs excuses pour avoir cru à
ce que c'est les [ __ ]
tmc 95,4 canap le maire ont fait subir à
patrice merci en tout cas pepita merci
d'avoir été avec nous je te fais des
nombres bisous c'est que je téléphone
[Applaudissements]
on